foreign
God
thou doest well
the Devils also believe and tremble but
will thou know o vain man that faith
without works is dead
welcome one and all to q a with elder
Randy skeet on faith and works here on
the word inspired I'm your host Denise
mccurtchen and before we proceed with
the program let's have a word of Prayer
dear Lord we thank you for your grace
and your mercies we thank you for the
privilege to learn about Christian
Living what it really means to be a
follower of you
faith and works
please guide us and I pray that your
Holy Spirit Will Will especially be upon
Elder Randy skeet I pray that you put
your words in his mouth and anoint him
oh God so that as he answers the
questions you will be the one speaking
through him please direct the
proceedings of this program in the name
of Jesus Christ amen amen amen amen and
while I'm here I will also say that I'm
joined by other special guests brother
Jody piagui brother Kelly Edwards and
sister jonise Hammond okay and our very
special guest today has come from it was
actually in Loma Linda California right
now right and harmed out the time to be
here with us today literally rushing
from one church program to this ministry
and we know that he has a sincere deep
feather and love for the word of God and
for the promulgation of the Gospel he
truly is a man of the word and has
focused his life spent and devoted all
of his energies into fulfilling his
purpose in Jesus Christ which is to take
the gospel to all the world for a
witness unto the end he has studied for
the ministry at Oakwood University and
Andrews theology Andrews University
Theological Seminary he is a husband and
he is a father to many please help me
welcome Elder Randy skeet
thank you very much
uh let me uh thank God for this
delightful privilege it really is to be
a part of this ministry that touches
many lives as you said correctly I just
left Loma Linda's campus spoke to the
students had an delightful time and then
we rushed over to this place where I'm
staying to answer the questions God's
people put to us so thank you again
Anisha let me say a word of prayer
father
remember the promise of James 1 verse 5.
if any of you lack wisdom let him ask of
God that giveth to all men liberally and
a British not and it shall be given him
give me that wisdom day God For Your
Glory first and for the blessing of
those who are listening in the name of
Jesus Christ I pray amen if you notice
any huskiness in my voice I have been
fighting a slight infection which is
going away now
I picked it up when I was in Hawaii last
week I got back from Hawaii on Wednesday
and I left on Thursday for Loma Linda
now I'm with my Good Sister Sister
Denisha so the voice has been
very busy so if you hear a little
huskiness just pray for me that the Lord
will continue the healing process
because I'm doing quite well and I thank
God for that and it's not a sacrifice to
rush it's a pleasure because dead people
can't rushed so I'm very grateful to God
that I can Rush from one place to the
next I really am when it gets cold in
Michigan where I live I simply say to
God father I thank you I'm alive to feel
cold when it gets into summer I'm alive
to feel hot and so you find a way to
view circumstances positively so the
Russian was a privilege and I thank God
I'm here I'm ready for the first
question
amen amen thank you so much Elder skeet
and we pray that you will fully recover
your health
by God's grace yes yes so our first
question is why should we study faith
and works
and how do we reconcile the two
very very comprehensive question why
should we study faith and works let us
go to Hebrews chapter 11.
verse 6.
Hebrews chapter 11 verse 6 we're
answering the question why should we
study faith and works
but without faith it is impossible to
please him let's stop right there it is
only by faith we can please God
whatsoever is not of faith is sin I
believe that's Romans 4 23 14 23 it is
only by faith that you and I can please
God this is how Jesus lived let's reason
our way to that conclusion let us go to
John 8 and read verse 29.
remember the question is why should we
study faith and works and how do the two
work together John 8 verse 29
this is Jesus speaking he says and he
that sent me is with me the father hath
not left me alone for I do always those
things that please him now keep those
words in mind Jesus did those things
that please God Hebrews 11 6 says
without faith it is impossible to please
God so if Jesus please God The Logical
to occlusion is and Theological
conclusion is that he lived a life of
Faith because there's no other way to
please God now let's go to First John
chapter 3 verse 22.
yeah
and whatsoever we ask
receive of him because we keep his
Commandments that's doing that's doing
keep reading now and do those things
that are pleasing in his sight the fact
that they're pleasing in the psych means
they are works of Faith because it is
only by faith you can please God but we
have pleasing in his sight that's faith
we have do his Commandments do the
things you cannot separate Faith from
works now if he's your chapter two let's
go to verse 8. it's well known I am sure
all your listeners can say it without
looking but let's go to Ephesians 2
reading from verse 8.
foreign
for by grace are ye saved through faith
yes and that not of yourselves it is the
gift of God everything
a lot of Works lest any man should boast
so you don't say it by your words but
listen to what he says about works in
the very next verse for we are his
workmanship ah God works on us why does
God work on us keep breathing created in
Christ Jesus unto good works God works
on us so that we may produce good works
are you following me
we are his workmanship if God works why
shouldn't we work God works because he
loves us he works on our behalf we are
his workmanship created in Christ Jesus
unto good works
now go to Titus Chapter 2 let's read
verse 14.
the question is why should we study
faith and works how do you reconcile the
two
Titus what is the chapter two
verse 14. okay who gave himself for us
that he might redeem us from all
iniquity and purify unto himself a
peculiar people
of good work good works now there's two
opposites in that verse who gave himself
for us that he might redeem us from all
iniquity those are bad words are you
following me yeah initially bad words
and purify unto himself a people A
peculiar people's jealous of good works
the iniquity bad Works uh zealous of
good works the works that God that
pleases that please God and so we have
faith and work you cannot separate the
two because it is faith that gives
evidence of the genuine nature it is
work sorry that gives evidence of the
genuine nature of the faith now this is
so basic and sincere serious that James
the brother of Jesus uses the creation
of Adam to demonstrate how faith and
works uh work together let us go to
James chapter two let's read verse 26.
for as the body without the spirit is
dead
so faith without works is dead
give evidence of a working Spirit a body
without the works is dead the same way
Adam was made but until God breathed
into his nostrils he was not alive he
was just made James says listen works
are the same way works are evidence that
you're alive now Dr Alicia you are in
medical school and they're polished
medical doctors listening
there's something called vital signs are
you following me yes all medical
professionals of this they they look for
Vital Signs whether you breathe in your
blood pressure whatever it is vital
signs are worked spiritually
a person is dead when there are no Vital
Signs whatsoever if you were to come
across someone lying on the sidewalk you
wanted to check whether he or she is
alive you would check for Vital Signs
not for the academic degrees or the
person's address vital signs in the life
of the Christian good words are vital
signs of Living Faith wow
without those works you do not have
faith
mm-hmm
that's what Jesus says okay let's go to
Luke 6 30 Luke 6 46. Luke by the way I
was a medical doctor Luke himself yes
yes
verse 46.
we're looking at the relationship
between faith and works why should we
study the subject absolutely essential
subject
Luke 6 verse 46 what does that say and
why call ye me Lord Lord Lord and do not
the things which I say and I would say I
don't works you see why are you calling
me Lord but there are no good works of
course produced by my spirit there must
be works in the life of the Christian as
an evidence that he or she has a living
faith a living faith must have vital
signs the vital signs that works not let
us go to John 14.
yes
which verse 15.
if you love me meet my Commandments that
it works you see it works are the only
way to prove your love for God you can
say all day I have faith I have faith I
have faith show me your faith by your
works are you following me now
uh let us go to uh John 14 verse 21.
he that hath my Commandments and keepeth
them those are the works yes those are
the words here is that love is me you
cannot separate love from good works
because good words Express the love
Express the faith read verse 23.
Jesus answered and said unto him if a
man loved me he will keep my words those
are the works that's enough let's go to
the next chapter John 15. mm-hmm
from verse One Elder skeet yes no no
from verse 12 12. this is my commandment
that ye love one another as I have loved
you 13 greater love hath no man than
this that a man will lay down his life
for his friends now listen to 14. ye are
my friends if there's a condition yes if
you do whatsoever I command you yes
there is a doing the doing is proof you
really have genuine Faith go to Luke 18.
and I'm trying to keep my opinions out
of this just giving my friends the word
of God Luke 18 let's read from verse 18.
and a certain ruler asked him saying
uh-huh
what shall I do to inherit eternal life
not just what shall I think what shall I
do to inherit eternal life keep reading
and Jesus said unto him why call thou me
good
none is good save one that is God
thou knows the Commandments uh-huh go on
that do not commit adultery do not kill
do not steal do not bear false witness
honor thy father and thy mother do that
do that says Christ of course by the
spirit of God this is evidence that you
have saving faith you cannot separate
Faith from works you see there are two
people who talk about faith in the Bible
mainly poor in the New Testament Paul
and James
and Paul and James are frequently
brought into Conflict by misguided
theologians or Bible students because
one two person says Paul preaches Faith
the other person says James preaches
salvation by work that's not the case
Paul is stressing justification that
instant act in which God justifies a
person like the Publican in Luke chapter
18 God be merciful to me a sinner in
that instant he was justified he went
down to his house Justified Luke 18 14
James is stressing now what kind of Life
do you live not if you've been Justified
that's what James is stressing what kind
of life you live where is the evidence
that you were indeed Justified as Paul
talks of justification James says now
show me the evidence if you're truly
Justified as Paul says it you will have
good works so Paul and James work
together faith and works they cannot be
separated
thank you for that robust Excursion of
scripture
yes yes first speaking about the fact
that without faith yes sorry sorry let's
go to Romans chapter four all right
let's go
let's read for verse 19.
and being not weak in faith
he considered not his own body now dead
when he was about 100 years old neither
yet the deadness of Sarah's womb let's
pause on that very very serious
statement Abraham's loins were dead
meaning he could not fall the children
anymore
Sarah's room womb was dead and buried
she could not get pregnant that's very
clear from that verse now that's the
Human Condition
but read verse 19 again
and being not weak in faith the faith
there is the faith that God has said you
have a child Abraham believes you would
have a child even though he and Sarah
had come to the place when neither one
of them were was reproductive neither
one was fertile yet he continued to
believe now that's his faith but we need
works for that Faith keep reading verse
20. he staggered not at the promise of
God through unbelief but was strong in
faith giving glory to God yes and being
fully persuaded that what he had
promised he was able to also perform let
me ask you this okay did Sarah
eventually have a son yes
did that require Abraham and Sarah to
come together or was it done by Skype
you are you following me or by you
didn't they have to come together that's
works are you with me even though
Abraham knew he was reproductively dead
even though he knew Sarah was dead he
also knew Sarah was reproductively dead
Abraham knew and Sarah knew God said
you'd have a child with that Faith they
came together as man and white and
silver got pregnant
wow wow that is Faith and works if
Abraham had said I believe I believe and
had not come together with Sarah there
would have been no ice
you cannot say I believe I believe I
believe it must be followed up with what
are you doing based on the fact you
believe God so loved the world he did
something he gave his only begotten son
God could not simply say I love the
world I love the world I love the world
well prove it he gave he did something
God has works we must have works why we
were made in God's image
um
God proves his love by works we prove
our faith with works and our love
amen amen that's why the Bible speaks of
The Obedience of faith
you believe you'll complete your degree
that's why you're doing it
that's right you have faith and works
every exam you take that's works
indeed indeed all right what's the next
question powerful oh this kid you
actually do you gave the Prelude I was
thinking of uh for this next question
which is how are we saved you know in
terms of reconciling with people's
writings with James however we say okay
we're served by Christ but the Bible
says by Grace I saved through faith that
not of yourself it is the gift of God
but listen to John 3 16. for God so
loved the world that he gave his only
begotten son that whosoever believeth
there's something you must do you have
to believe now let's go to First John
chapter three read verse 23 first John
23 read verse 23 my good sister yes
verse 23 of John of First John chapter
three and this is his Commandments this
is his commandment what response does
God want to his Commandments obedience
that's works are you following me this
is his commandment go on
that we should believe on the
on the name of his son Jesus Christ and
and love one another as he gave us
commandment we have been commanded to
believe in Jesus
when you believe you've obeyed this
works
then it is God who saves you but God
will not save you apart from your
exercise of faith in him and that faith
is evidence by the work what's the work
you obey God I believe
now let us go to Acts chapter eight we
read 36 and 37.
and as they went on their way they came
unto a certain water yes that's the
Ethiopian
yes and the eunuch said see here is
water what does hinder me to be baptized
in other words what do I need to do
go on listen to Philip and Philip said
if thou believest with all thine heart
thou mayest faith is also a work
what does Philip saying this is what you
need to do believe you need to do that
so in a certain sense faith is also a
work because we're commanded to believe
First John 3 23 faith is a kind of work
if you believe you may be baptized and
he said I believe
than Philip baptizing so we have Philip
during the baptizing the Euler doing the
believing we have God saving we have a
weird one doing the believing you have
that combination it is God who does the
actual deliverance from sin but we have
to believe salvation is the work of
cooperation
You Must Believe
whether your belief is as large as a
mustard seed or an oak tree you must
believe because God does not work
miracles to honor doubt he on his face
powerful
what a punchline okay God does not work
miracles to honor doubt no he does not
faith
amen amen you know it reminds me of
Revelation Chapter 14 verse 12 where it
says hear some patience of the Saints of
the sins that keep the Commandments of
God and have the faith the Commandments
yes but the work is carried out by the
power of God in you
you see Jesus had to get Jesus's work
showed his faith
his work showed his faith
go to James chapter one
yes and which verse Elder ski
uh let's read
no James chapter two two let's read from
verse 14.
what does it profit my brethren though a
man say he hath faith and have not works
can Faith save him now that's a very
serious statement because Ellen White
makes it clear she said Faith itself has
no saving value
only God can save you she said Faith
itself has mostly every value faith is
the way we hold on to what God has done
for us you know when you go to the the
gas station to put oil in your in your
car there's a little paper uh what's
that little thing a little funnel yes
that's Faith that's how to get the oil
in you see faith is how God that allows
God to put the oil of Salvation into us
that is the faith if you don't use that
you scattle all over the place and so
Faith James says what does the
prophetism man say I have faith and have
not works kept faith alone saving keep
reading if a brother or sister be naked
and destitute of daily food yes and one
of you say unto them depart in peace be
warmed and filled notwithstanding you
give them not those things which are
needful to the body
what's the point where are the works
give them some food give them some
clothes that's worse
you see keep reading even so faith
not works is dead being alone and I call
that the deadliness of loneliness faith
without works is dead and a lot of us we
have a dead face so we're dead people
walking around
The Living Faith is the faith that
produces works
keep reading keep reading
that there is one God uh-huh thou do as
well the Devils also believe and tremble
you see but James is saying you the
church member you believe there's one
God but there's no evidence of you don't
obey him there are no words the Devils
believe
how can your faith be the faith of
devils the Devils believe they don't
produce works of Faith you're a
Christian you must produce works of
Faith the Devils believe and tremble
that faith without works is dead same
message in verse 17 same message in the
last verse of that chapter keep reading
was not Abraham Our Father justified by
his works when he had offered Isaac his
son upon the altar let's pause right no
finish reading finish reading see us
thou how Faith brought with his words
my Works was Faith made perfect that's
right our faith that has no works is an
imperfect faith and nothing is perfect
can function in your salvation are you
following me nothing imperfect can
contribute to your salvation Faith did
not works is not perfect now let us go
to Genesis 22 see what James is writing
about Genesis 22 let's read from verse
11 from verse 10. Abraham is about to
kill Isaac he's about to try
to reading for verse 10. and Abraham
stretched forth his hand and took the
knife to slay his son uh-huh and the
angel of the Lord called unto him out of
heaven and said Abraham Abraham he said
here am I Jeremiah and he said lay not
to thine hand on upon the lad neither do
anything unto him for now I know that
now pause God says now I know why did
God say that because Abraham got up
early in the morning he sell his ass
took his young men with him took the
fire took him alive started walking
identified the Mountain built his altar
put the vote on the altar banglades of
his son did all of that all of that they
raised the knife then God said now I
know based on what he did not just what
he said I believe God said now I know it
is works that allow God to say now I
know you really want to obey me you've
decided to keep the Sabbath no I know
keep reading for now I know that famous
God keep going seeing thou has not
withheld thy son thy only son from me
God watched as Abraham went through all
those steps he tied up his son put him
on the altar raised so all that is works
all that is worse God said I've seen
this now I know now God always knew but
Abraham really is the one who's being
taught God said my sister listen to me
carefully and all those are watching
there are many believers who need to
give God the opportunity to say now I
know
because we don't do what God says so God
cannot say now I know we talk a lot
Jesus said these people are with me with
their lips but their hearts are far from
me a lot of us are praise the Lord
praise the Lord I love you no God says
show me God is from Missouri
I hope you understand what I'm trying to
say it's the show mistake God is from
Missouri God says show me that works
and Ben thought says now I know
that you are what you say and now I know
that you love me now I know you're
committed now I know says God based on
what you've done
now let's go back to James now chapter
two let three from first and against 23
or 20 21 I think this is James
chapter 2 from verse 21 31 yes was not
Abraham Our Father
justified by works
made rights with God made right because
if he had not obeyed God he would not
have been Justified he obeyed he worked
of course by grace through faith now
keep reading when he had yes when he had
offered Isaac his son upon the altar see
is thou how Faith wrought with his works
and by works was Faith made perfect keep
going and the scripture was fulfilled
could save Abraham believed God and it
was counted on excuse me it was imputed
unto him for righteousness and how was
that Faith perfected by The Works yes
keep reading and he was called the
friend of God now listen to Jesus we
read
yeah my friends if you do whatsoever
yeah Abraham was God's friends because
he did
I hope you're with me yeah he did the
Bible says he's my friend why James says
because he did these things
Jesus says you're my friends if you do
what did I tell you but we do to the
power of God you see you cannot separate
faithful mercs because anyone can go to
God you see that's why we're judged by
our works not by our faith
we profess faith in God we prove it by
our work so the Bible said we shall in
the Judgment God will look at our words
not and what he said what we did the
life you lived
because it's very easy to say I love God
then he says we'll return the tithe and
we say no I love God keep the Sabbath we
say no I love God forgive that person
who hurt you no I love God apologize to
the person you heard no we say we love
God
then God says where's the words
you know your wife has a birthday or
your husband and you say happy birthday
the person is looking for something
where's the gift keep your happy
birthday where's the gifts
we know that
but we try to ignore it when it comes to
the Bible
very special
yes well I'll Escape out yes powerful
powerful powerful connection of
scripture powerful connection of
scripture and friends I hope we're
seeing how practical this is like the
only way we can show that we are
Christians is if we live as Christians
and that's how the two faith and works
our shows that's right
exactly exactly exactly so I'm going to
now bring on brother Kelly Edwards Elder
skeet you've heard him many times ask
questions
God bless you yes first I want to say
thank you again
make a U-turn that changed my life which
one was that make a U-turn okay my
brother testimony that you give with
your car that you use to drive fast and
you ask yes yes yes yes thank you it
made a difference in my driving skills
now so I take my time while I drive God
is good God is good God is good
my first question is I'll read
Revelation uh 3 18 first and it says yes
yes the Church of the of laodicea Jesus
says eye of me gold tried in the fire
but now you're rich
and eyes with ice house that thou mayest
see two questions I have is yes what
does this mean and the second one is can
we buy salvation all right good question
based on the verse you read let's go to
Isaiah 55.
and anyone who has it can read it Isaiah
55 let's read verse 1. this is where
John is quoting from
Isaiah 55 let's read verse 1. now let's
read microscopically so we don't
misunderstand the word by in Revelation
3 18. Isaiah 55 verse 1 says
that come in the waters that had no
money come here buy and eat you have no
money come and buy you have no money but
come and buy keep reading buy wine and
milk without money and without price
in other words get it you have no you
cannot buy innocence
take advantage of the fact it's
available that's what by means you can't
buy salvation you can afford it it is
self vicious based on the sacrifice of
Christ you can't buy that so we see
clearly they say buy without money take
advantage of this offer the availability
of Grace of forgiveness because
probation will put an end to all of that
are you following me so buy it take
advantage of it so we go back to
Revelation 3 18. I counsel it buy of me
gold tried in a fire goal represents
Faith let's go to First Peter chapter
one
let's read for several
First Peter chapter one verse 7 says and
so godliness broadly kindliness
chapter one second Peter chapter one
verse seven
second Peter chapter one verse 7 says
and so godliness brotherly kindness
no First Peter 1 7 3 I think you read
second be the first time confused me a
little First Peter 1 7 it says and that
and that the trial of your faithful
preciousness though it betrayed with
fire so we have faith gold represents
Faith that's tried in the fire and
purify so God says I come to the Bible
you see God told him in verse 17 you're
wretched miserable poor like the naked
they said we're rich increasing Goods
don't have need of nothing
is absolutely different you're poor
you're wretched and so he said by gold
that you might be rich the riches that
we must strive for Are Spiritual riches
first
God it mean you'd be rich with respect
to chess or you know J.P Morgan although
that's fine too don't misunderstand me
the riches we need are the riches of
Salvation The Riches of the gracious of
Jesus Christ and so he says buy of me go
tried in a fire that I must be rich and
a white women that I may be clothed and
at the shame of thy nakedness not appear
nakedness into the world so sin
God clothed Adam and eighth because the
influence of leaves weren't working God
clothed them representing the
righteousness of Christ so Christ says
get white women that always be clothed
and the shame of thy nakedness and that
the effects of sin do not corrupt your
lives you see and then he says and
anoint thine eye with eyes may see
because he said you apply
and so he gives them the antidote for
all the conditions they're suffering
that they did not know all of that is
through Christ so when he says buy it
it's not money it is take advantage of
an offer I am offering you gold safe I'm
offering your rim to cover your
nakedness I'm offer you I sound so you
can see your true condition Psalm 119
Verse 18 open down mine eyes that I may
behold want to sing out of thy law and
so God has to open our eyes and it is
the spirit through the word that opens
the eyes Because unless God opens our
eyes through his word we cannot see our
true condition we will be Sinners we'll
see ourselves as Saints
and this message is the laodicea and we
are Leo this year generally speaking yes
they're individual exceptions but we are
generally corporately laodicea and this
is Christ's recommendation this is his
Angelo this is his remedy this year
the goal of the faith the white Raymond
of righteousness and the eyesight of the
spirits of the word of God yes amen amen
to buy it is to take advantage of the
fact it's available it's freely off amen
thank you so much Pastor skip for
answering that question that came to me
was seek ye first the kingdom of God and
his righteousness and all these things
added on to you you're so distracted the
worldly things that we don't seek
spiritual things that text came to me so
may God give us the power to seek
spiritual things instead of us
yes yes absolutely can add to that yes
uh in my second question is
uh Jesus lists Faith among the weightier
matters of the law what is the
relationship between faith and the law
and look I'll read Luke 18 8.
okay
I tell you that he will avenge them
speedily nevertheless and the son of man
cometh how he find faith on the earth
uh-huh
so my question yes uh what is the
relationship between faith and the law
all right the law of God is an
expression of the very righteousness of
God
the central teaching of the Bible is
righteousness by faith are you following
me Paul calls it The Obedience of Faith
the relationship between faith and the
law is that the keeping of God's law is
the highest expression of my faith or
your faith
you understand me I've actually dwelling
power of Jesus Christ that's how Jesus
lived in John chapter 15 verse 10. if he
keep my Commandments he shall abide in
my love even as I have kept my father's
Commandments and abide in his love Jesus
kept the Commandments through faith in
the father's word let's go to John 6 go
to John 6 John 6.
read verse 57 listen to Christ
John 6 57 mm-hmm
John 6 57 says
and as the living father has sent me and
yes I live by the father stop how do you
live by the father finish the verse now
so he that
eat at me uh-huh even He Shall Live By
Me Jesus is saying the same way I live
by the father you must live by me but we
know that Jesus said man shall not live
by bread alone but by every word so
Jesus lived by the father because he
lived an obedience to the father's word
the father's Commandments that's how we
will sustained we are to live the same
way with respect to Jesus Christ faith
in the word of God produces the
obedience to God's laws that's why it's
The Obedience of faith in other words
you cannot obey God's law without faith
amen amen and you cannot have faith
without exercising obedience
you cannot remove Faith from the law of
God
because it is only by faith we please
God and we please God by obeying God and
so faith in the word of God and the law
of God is the word of God
Genesis Revelation is the word of God we
must have faith in the word of God and
the law of God is part of the word of
God and so to keep God's law requires
living faith in God
amen amen remember the law has letter
and spirit are you with me it is easy
because
I've never killed them you won't ever
shocked anyone never cut off anyone's
head I have not killed wrong Jesus said
you've been angry you murderer you
understand to keep the law at that level
you must have faith
that's why Jesus said accept your
righteousness shall exceed the
righteousness of the scribes and
Pharisees you shall in no case enter
into the Kingdom of Heaven Matthew 5
verse 20. then he says in verse 21 you
have heard that it was said by them of
all time Thou shalt not kill and whoever
shall kill shall be danger of the
Judgment but I say unto you whosoever is
angry with his brother without a cause
shall be in danger of the judgment and
so Jesus says the righteousness that
exceeds that of the Pharisees is the
righteousness expressed in clean and
simple obedience to God's law not read
the letter but the spirit of the law
amen amen amen you cannot separate the
law from faith faith amen and Pastor
that's one of the words that you love to
stress when you preach is obedience
absolutely sometimes it looks like you
want to put it in our heads yes I do
I do so you don't understand my brother
I cannot understand our concept so
simple and we resisted God wants one
thing from you oh baby yes yes
well let me not get work till I don't
want my blood pressure to go up but we
must learn to obey God amen amen
okay God bless you my handsome brother
God thank you thank you Pastor I have
one more question yes
how can we be laborers together with God
and partakers of the divine nature I'll
read First Corinthians 3 9 right and
second Peter chapter one verse four
right so First Corinthians 3 9 says for
we are laborers together with God this
is our God's husband area ye are God's
Building all right let us go to Matthew
20 liberals together with God
Matthew 28.
28 readings 18 to 20 18 to 20 and
resistance
and Jesus came and spake unto them
saying yes all power is given unto me in
heaven and in Earth go ye therefore and
teach All Nations by tizing them in the
name of the father and of the son and of
the Holy Ghost keep them to observe all
things whatsoever I have commanded you
hello I am with you always even until
the end of the world we have liberals
together with God
all right Jesus sends the disciples to
preach go to Mark chapter 3.
3 read verse 13 and 14.
13 and
13 to 15 and he going up into a mountain
that they should be with him and that he
might send them forth to preach that's
collaborous with God and to have power
to heal sicknesses sicknesses
that is collaborating with God
God empowers you he sends you
so we work with God now go to Acts
chapter 2.
read verse 47.
verse 47 says
[Music]
and the Bible says praising God and
having favor with all the people and the
Lord added to the church daily such as
should be saved who preached
the disciples
the apostles who added to the church
God God so they're working together
they're collaborous with God You Preach
I will sue my spirit convict and move
them towards an acceptance of Jesus
Christ You Preach I will add to the
church
together with God
now there's another question you had
with that
other question was
okay
no I think that was that was the only
question how can we become laborers
together with God partakers of divine
nature ah okay let's go to Second Peter
chapter one
[Music]
how can we partake of the divine nature
now we cannot be God but we must partake
of the divine nature how is that
possible let's go to Second Peter
chapter one
we'll read from verse 1 to verse 4.
so one to four says
Simon Peter a servant Apostle of Jesus
Christ to them that have or obtained
like preciousness
of God and our Savior Jesus Christ
Grace and peace be multiplied unto you
through the knowledge of God we have the
word knowledge through the knowledge go
on
and of Jesus our lord keep reading
according as his divine power had given
unto us all things that pertain unto
life and God knows how through the
knowledge of him knowledge again
to glory and virtue keep reading whereby
are given unto us exceeding great and
precious promises
found where are those promises found
in the Bible in the Bible the word of
God whereby are given to us exceeding
great and precious promises keep reading
that by these you might be part Seekers
what is this the promises from the word
of God that by these by the word of God
we may be partakers of the divine nature
it is when you surrender to God you live
by his word in that act of obedience
through the power of God that's how we
partake of the divine nature that's how
we come into Union with Christ through
surrender and obedience to his word
of God in it
the word has the divine nature of God in
it the word contains the life of God the
word contains the character of God
so when you receive the word
and Obey it that is how the divine
nature Works in you So when you say
you're Christian and you have no time
for this you cannot take part of the
divine nature of God you cannot it is
through the word obeyed through faith
that you and I partake of the divine
nature and he or she who lives by the
divine nature cannot be overcome by sin
too many of us are too busy for this
a man or a woman too busy for the word
of God is too busy to be safe
it is by the word of God we partake of
the divine nature
amen amen amen
thank you Pastor and you're welcome
you're welcome I pray that God help us
to yoke up with him so that we can live
in obedience and obey his laws and may
we put him first thank you again sir
God bless you
amen amen thank you so much Elder skin
and brother Jody we sense the energy the
fever praise God for the word praise God
and while we are here I would like to
acknowledge those of you that are
joining I see sister Amanda walls from
Twitter thank you for being here on zoom
and on YouTube we have some brethren
from Malawi Malawi God bless Malawi yes
Emmanuel she's SoMo and we have one of
us even some friends from Guyana
is from London God bless London yes yes
amen and someone else from Newfoundland
Canada Shane Greece yes
Newfoundland Canada that's the eastern
part of Canada wow
I have to travel hey well you know Elvis
Keith when we all get to Heaven by God's
grace you got to show me around this
world I will I will no charge
no charge
yes we welcome all of you watching from
Jamaica Trinidad persons are putting
where they're coming from in the chat
Yvonne and iska yes but in any case let
us continue with our last two questions
the time is upon us
I hope we're seeing that the questions
that um brother uh Kelly Edwards acts
pertain to the work that God does in us
and that we produce as Christians and
these next two questions will focus a
little bit more on the faith aspect and
then also on our mind set
so the next question Elder skeet is the
father of the demon possessed boy
and Sid with tears Lord I believe help
thou mind unbelief Mark 9 24. can we
simultaneously doubt and have faith how
do we build our faith in God
a lot of Romans 10 read verse 17.
so then Faith cometh by hearing yes
and hearing by the word of God
let me say this clearly there is nothing
God does that bypasses his word nothing
Christians try to bypass this to find a
shortcut there is nothing God does that
bypasses his word because Jesus is the
word Jesus is the Alpha and the Omega
he's the a to the Z God does not bypass
his word
amen amen
Psalm 138 verse 2 God has magnified his
word above all his lame
okay amen amen what else anything else I
need to say about that question no I'll
just keep no this well I mean I guess
there's one thing is it possible I mean
then the man said help thou mind
unbelief but he had Faith Can we Down
Heaven he did not have a lot of faith
God is such a nice person let me explain
this
if you have faith as much as a bathroom
sink are you with me a bathtub
you bring that to Christ you must
exercise all of that
if your faith is only a thimble God says
exercise that
either way God is pleased the man only
had a symbol worth of faith
Jesus essentially said exercising
then he said help my unbelief because he
knew his faith was weak he wasn't
believing and doubting because God does
not reward out
are you with me let me show you that
very clearly go to Mark chapter not Mark
Matthew 13 read verse 58.
Matthew 13 verse 58 for this people's
heart
is
verse 58 oh 58 yes yes yes my fault all
right and he did not many mighty works
there because of their unbelief yes yes
where there's unbelief God does not work
his power as he would like he did